joli acheté par son premier achat de
bitcoin pour cette cliente
ouverte fin juin à versailles la crypto
station est un comptoir permettant
d'acheter ou de vendre plus de 300
crypto monnaie des monnaies virtuelles
qui n'existent que sur internet
la plus emblématique et le bitcoin c'est
une monnaie qui a été vraiment créé
suite à la crise financière de 2009
manque de confiance en les institutions
le bacon aujourd'hui et décentralisé
c'est à dire qu'elle n'est régi par
aucun état souverain
aucune société aucune personne
aujourd'hui il est possible de payer en
bitcoin sur plusieurs sites internet ou
encore dans certains cafés parisiens
présents sur tous les continents sa
valeur est déterminé par l'offre et la
demande et fluctuent tous les jours lors
de notre tournage il valait un peu plus
de 6700 dollars alors d'aujourd'hui
c'est un marché qui se porte très bien
nous sommes actuellement je crois 300
milliards de capitalisation boursière
pour tout les crypto menées et nous
pensons nous aussi tout aux stations que
ça va aller bien au dessus tout ça est
que nous si tout se passe bien cette
amené à remplacer toutes les
applications que vous connaissez
aujourd'hui normalement
cette technologie devrait distribuer
tous ces secteurs dans les dix ans
non je trouve vraiment bien d'avoir des
personnes physiques en face parce qu
interagir avec son ordinateur
et quand on comprend pas certaines
choses on n'ose pas franchir le pas
alors qu'ici bas comme vous avez pu le
voir il ya des gens qu'on franchit pas
tout de suite en fait pour acquérir ou
vendre des bitcoins chez crypto station
il faut être majeur et présenter une
pièce d'identité